are you aware of cop 26
i know that i'm not aware of that
particular conference do you think we're
in the midst of a climate emergency i
think that it's a
cyclic natural event
caused by
rotations of the sun
rural west virginia is a long way from
washington and even further from glasgow
but these are the people president biden
has to convince at home if he's to
become the global leader on climate
change
he left for europe with wife jill
pledging half a trillion dollars to
transition to clean energy over a
billion metric tons of emission
reductions
at least 10 times bigger on climate than
any bill that has ever passed before but
biden may yet turn up to cop 26 with
empty promises unable to get his own
party to vote for his plan a last-ditch
attempt to unite democrats on his wider
spending bill today ultimately
unsuccessful
the bigger issue though is uniting a
country on climate change and weaning
america off coal and gas and onto
renewable energy
nowhere is that challenge more
pronounced than west virginia
a state built on black gold now
devastated by its decline these coal
workers and activists discussing how to
rebuild their communities what do people
make of president biden and his climate
agenda his climate plans
west virginia uh probably is not uh the
most
enamored with some of his rhetoric
the ideas that they're just going to
shove it down somebody's throat
it's not going to fly here
president biden wants to be the world
leader on tackling climate change in
glasgow there'll be big numbers and
bigger ambitions
but at home diversifying from coal and
gas remains bitterly divisive
even in places devastated by extreme
weather where we're standing now is
completely underwater these houses and
these churches were all
flooded angie campaigned for clean water
access in west virginia she hopes cop 26
will be a breakthrough
it is a marker to say the united states
is ready to make a commitment on climate
a big commitment
i'm hopeful that west virginia and the
rest of the world will take note of that
and follow that
president biden knows the next week
could define his presidency
america's climate credibility is on the
line his credibility as a diplomatic
forces too martha calmer sky news west
virginia